okay let's talk about this
2018
proposal
to darpa so i guess who's drafted the
proposal is it
equal health but the proposal is to do
re so equal health is technically
uh a u.s funded organization primarily
and then the idea was
to do work at wuhan institute of
virology with yeah so is with equal
health yes so eco health basically that
um the one institute of virology was
going to go and they were going to
collect these viruses and store them at
uh viral but they're also going to do
the actual task according it's a really
important point according to their
proposal the actual work was going to be
done at the lab of ralph barrack at the
university of north carolina who's
probably the world's leading expert on
corona coronaviruses
and so
we know
that darpa didn't fund that work
um we know
i think quite well that ralph barrack's
lab
in part because it was not uh funded by
by darpa they didn't do that specific
work what we don't know
is well what work was done at the wuhan
institute of virology because wiv was
part of this proposal
they had access to all of the plans they
had done they had their own capacity and
they had already done a lot of work in
genetically engine genetically altering
this exact category of viruses they had
created
a chemeric mixed
viruses they had done
they had mastered pretty much all of the
steps in order to achieve this thing
that they applied for funding with
ecohealth to do and so the question is
did the wuhan institute of virology go
through with that research anyway and in
my mind there's that's a very very real
possibility would certainly explain why
they're giving no information
and
as you know i've been a member of the
world health organization expert
advisory committee on human genome
editing which dr tedros created in the
aftermath of the announcement of the
world's first crispr babies
and it was just basically the exact same
story so ho john quay a chinese
scientist he was not a first-year
scientist but a perfectly adequate
second-tier
scientist came to the united states
learned all of these capacities went
back to china and said well there's a
much more permissive environment
i'm gonna you know be a world leader i'm
gonna establish both myself and china so
in every scientific field we're seeing
this this same thing where you kind of
learn a model and then you do it in
china so is it possible
that the wuhan institute of virology
with this exact game plan
was doing it anyway do we
possible we have no clue
what work was being done at the wuhan
institute of virology it seems extremely
likely
that at the wuhan institute of virology
and this is certainly the u.s government
position there was the work that was
being done in dr shah's lab
but that wasn't the whole wiv we know at
least according to the united states
government that there was the chinese
military that pla was doing work there
were they doing this kind of work not to
create a bio weapon
but in order to understand these viruses
maybe to develop vaccines and treatments
it it seems like a very very
logical possibility uh and then so we
know that the the one instead of
virology had all of the skills we know
that they were part of this
proposal and then you have peter dazak
who knows all of this that at that time
in february of 2020 we didn't know
but then he comes swinging out of the
gate saying anybody who's raising this
possibility
of a lab incident origin
is a conspiracy theorist i mean it
really
makes him look in my mind very very bad
and not to at least be somewhat
open-minded on this because he knows all
the details he knows that
it's not zero percent i mean there's no
way in his mind could you even argue
that so it's potential because of the
bias because of your focus i mean it
could be the
anthony fauci masks thing whereas he
knows there's some significant
probability that this is happening but
in order to
preserve good relations with our chinese
colleagues we want to make sure we tell
a certain kind of narrative so it's not
really lying it's
doing the best possible
action at this time to help the world
not that this already happened yeah but
that's how like
yeah i i think it's quite likely that
that was the story that he was telling
himself
but it's
that le that lack of transparency
in my mind is fraudulent um that the
word that we were struggling to
understand something that we didn't
understand
and that i just think that
people who possess that kind of
information especially when um the
existence like his the entire career of
peter dezak is based on u.s taxpayers
there's a debt
that comes with that and that debt is
honesty and transparency and for all of
us and our you talked about your
girlfriend checking your phone for all
of us
being honest and and transparent in the
most difficult times is really difficult
if it were easy everybody would do it
and that's you know i just feel that
that uh peter was
the opposite of transparent and then
went on the offensive and then
um uh had the gall of joining i know we
can talk about this this
highly compromised
joint study
process with the the the
international experts and their chinese
government counterparts and used that as
a way of furthering this
um
in my mind fraudulent narrative um that
it almost certainly came from natural
origins and um and the lab origin was
extremely unlikely
just to stick briefly on the proposal to
wrap that up because i do think
in a in a kind of jon stewart way
if you heard that uh a bit he yeah sort
of kind of like common sense
way
the 2018 proposal
to darpa from eco health alliance and
honesty virology
just seems like a bit of a smoking gun
to me like that
um so there's this excellent book that
people should read uh called viral the
search for the origin of kova19
matt ridley and alina chan i think alina
is in mit
probably visit the broad yeah at broad
institute yeah yeah
so she uh i heard her in an interview
give this analogy of
unicorns yeah and uh
where
basically somebody writes a proposal to
add horns to horses
the proposal is rejected
and then a couple of years later or a
year later a unicorn shows up
in the place where they're proposing to
do it i mean that's so i had and then
everyone was like yeah i is natural
origin it's like it's possible it's
natural origin like we haven't detected
a unicorn yet and this is the first time
we've detected a unicorn or
it could be this massive organization
that was
planning is fully equipped has like a
history of being able to do this stuff
has the world experts to do it has the
funding has the motivation to add horns
to horses and now a unicorn shows up and
they're saying nope
yeah definitely
definitely natural well that connects to
the to what you your first question of
how do i get to my 85 and here's here's
a summary
of that of that answer and so it's what
i said in my 60 minutes uh interview a
long time ago of all the gin joints and
all the towns and all the world the
quote from from casablanca
and so of all the places in the world
where we have an outbreak of a sars-like
bat coronavirus it's not in the area of
the natural habitat of the horseshoe
bats it's the one city in china
with the first and largest
level four virology lab which actually
wasn't even using it they were doing
level three and and level two for this
work where they had the world's largest
collection of bat coronaviruses um where
they were doing aggressive experiments
designed to make these scary viruses
scarier where they had been part of an
application
to insert a furan cleavage site able to
infect human cells
and where
when the outbreak happened we had a
virus that was ready ready for action to
infect humans and to this day better
able to infect humans than any other
species including including bats and
then from day one
there's this massive cover-up and then
on top of that
in spite of lots of efforts by lots of
people there's basically no evidence for
the natural origin hypothesis everything
that i've described just now is
circumstantial but there's a certain
point
of where you add up the circumstances
and you see this seems pretty pretty
likely i mean if we're getting to a
hundred percent we are not at a hundred
percent by any means there still is a
possibility of a natural origin and if
we find that great but from everything
that i know that's how i get to my 85.
you